raymond barre lui était à toulouse
l'ancien premier ministre a évoqué les
droits de l'homme et surtout
l'immigration daniel brême était dans la
salle
pour ce forum auquel il assistait fera
près d'un millier de personnes
appartenant au réseau barriste animée
par charles millon l'ancien premier
ministre a longuement évoqué les droits
de l'homme dans les pays de l'est
à propos de la france tout en insistant
sur la nécessité du bon accueil pour
l'étranger il a ajouté à ce qui plaide
pour une limitation de l'immigration
nous nous devons dire que c'est
justement dans la mesure où notre pays
traite dignement et loyalement les
étrangers venaient vie venus vivre sur
son sol dans la légalité que la
nécessaire rigueur à l'encontre des
immigrés illégaux pourra s'exercer à ce
qu'ils regretteraient à ce qu'ils
regretteraient cette rigueur
nous pourrons alors faire remarquer que
le refus des tricheurs de l'immigration
demeure la meilleure façon de protéger
la tranquillité et l'intégration des
étrangers au statut régulier traitant
ensuite du terrorisme raymond barre a
déclaré aucune faiblesse n'est
acceptable
l'opinion française a conçu beaucoup de
fierté lorsque la justice française ça
fait prévaloir l'état de droit sur la
raison d'état